Hi tiktok I'm making this video hum to answer two subscribers
who asked me the question in the comments no it was inbox I think.
They asked me uh some questions about my nursing profession
in Quebec so I wanted to know what were the reasons that
pushed me to do nursing training and what was my training path?
Ok no to answer the first question I chose nursing
because I thought it was the profession that suited me the most.
I am someone who always takes care of his loved ones.
Um I'm uh how they say I'm very concerned I'm uh someone who
likes to take care of others I'm a calm person and I was
looking for a job that would give me the feeling of bringing
positive into the life of someone I wanted to feel useful to as a person.
Ok so that's why I chose the treatments ok just wanted to feel useful
ok in a concrete way so I chose this and the training in fact I had
the possibility either to go to university or to go to cgep but I
preferred to go to cgep because I think that um the follow-up is very
how they say the three years of training there when you complete them
you have a really good preparation for the exams uh of the order in
the professional exams and when I came out of the cgp I fell directly in c.
Sld and I developed my autonomy very quickly.
I still had some knowledge but I was doing I
had a really good ability to make connections.
Ok so if it's to be done again yes I'll go back to the subject again despite
the fact that it's a training that is that
is uh heavy a bit that requires a lot.
I will do it again without hesitation despite the fact that I am still at
university and now I am finishing my baccalaureate because I wanted to yes I
have a training that to judge complete for me but I wanted to have more skills
and why not especially more professional opportunities because at the moment
there are many positions at the public level even of the private sector that
are offered at the uh level that are offered rather by
hum of Tunisian nurses and about what?
Later I intend to specialize in dental medicine and so these are the
reasons that push me a little bit to do my bac ok but otherwise from a
personal point of view I could have just stayed uh continue to practice
with my deck but I went to the baccalaureate level to have more skills
more opportunities and why not later we start my training in dental medicine?
So there you go,
I hope I answered.